Terminator Genisys is directed by Alan
Taylor and stars Arnold Schwarzenegger
Jason Clark Jai Courtney and emilia
clark and takes place in the middle of
the timeline of Terminator 1 and a
futuristic timeline of some kind it's
all sort of meshed together in an
attempt to weave through the first two
films while also adding to them in this
futuristic time period a terminator is
sent back as we know in 1984 to destroy
Sarah Connor and just like in the first
film Kyle Reese gets sent back in time
to try to stop that from happening but
this time around an older version of the
t800 played again by Schwarzenegger is
there protecting Sarah Connor and has
taught her to be a badass already she's
no longer a fearful waitress she's
already the Sarah Connor from t2 and
this big corporation is about to launch
an app called Genesis that connects
everyone's electronic devices that is
going to blow up everyone kill everyone
and everyone has to stop that from
happening and that's all I'm gonna say
about the plot of this movie if you've
seen any of the trailers you
unfortunately know a lot more about the
plot that you shouldn't know that I will
not ruin just in case you haven't
watched any of the incredibly spoiler if
ik trailers that disappointed me quite a
bit because I can tell you that
virtually every single action set piece
except for the very last one has been
ruined for you in those trailers which
is vastly dumb now I'm a huge fan of the
first two terminators I've liked them my
entire life I think not only are they
incredibly fun science fiction action
movies they're important movies these
are movies that had to happen for us to
get to a place that we are now in today
those two films both pioneered
incredible animatronic and CGI effects
and are still timeless classics to this
day and Genesis tries to explain certain
things that happen in the first two
films while also adding a lot to them
some of the things I liked are the
little things they explained like for
instance in the first Terminator when
Kyle Reese lands back from
time-traveling he lands all hard he
splats right on the concrete and I was
always like why did he land so terribly
an Arnold head like this epic intro this
movie gives you a reason for that which
are cool there are little bits of
connective tissue here this film makes
between the first two and this one that
added to it that improved
but for the most part I found things
they did with the time line to be
incredibly confusing really convoluted
and some of it makes no sense looking
back in fact this movie in a lot of ways
really ruins the first two movies in
regards to the time line those first two
movies are always going to be good I'm
never going to say the sequel ruins your
other films that are good that can't
happen in my opinion those are good
movies they're always going to be good
movies but the problem here is that
looking back on them and then trying to
connect them with Genesis it's virtually
impossible there are so many plot holes
now it's like they tried to do so many
different things with this timeline to
create a new story when I really feel
like they should have just went in a
different direction how many times can
you have Sarah Cana and John Cana be in
the same story fine it's like okay I get
it
some should happen with John Connor and
Sarah Connor let's do something else
there had to have been something else of
interest that happened during the
Terminator storyline there had to have
been something else besides the same two
people over and over again but pushing
the story aside let's talk about the
characters for a minute at first I felt
like Emilia Clarke was just doing a
really bad Linda Hamilton impression but
her character did grow on me as the film
proceeded she was a badass she was
really tough in the role and she was
very believable in that aspect but I got
to be honest I think her and Jason
Clarke really were over selling their
performances in this movie there were
times where you were just looking at
them and you're like they're acting
right now and that's not a good sign
let's talk a little bit about Jai
Courtney look I got nothing against him
he's probably a really nice guy but I
just I find him very bland in movies and
he's in all these big movies like
diehard five and Jack Reacher and the
divergent films and he's just very
serviceable I've never really found him
to be great in any film and he is again
serviceable and most of the reforms in
this movie are serviceable save for one
the best part of this movie is what I
was most concerned about and that is
Arnold Schwarzenegger I was really
afraid that he was just gonna be like
yes I'm the Terminator and here I am in
the Bing and terminate the movie again
and blah blah blah
ha I'm back there's ah ha ha shut up
this is
all of it is ah stupid I'm dumb
but he was actually the best part of
this movie he really still worked as a
terminator there
a good string of humor throughout this
movie that was one of the best parts of
this movie it's actually a pretty funny
film and that aspect of him the humor
was great
I liked him in the role he was really
good still but the film's attempts to
connect to the originals using a CGI
Arnold and actually doing shot-for-shot
recreation of scenes straight out of
Terminator just felt weird it was just
odd it was like the best parts of this
film were when you could see them
actually cutting a scene exactly like
James Cameron cut it and those attempts
to throw back to the originals just
didn't work for me because it felt like
a different movie was suddenly happening
under a different director the other
issue I have here with this movie is
that I don't really feel much of it was
actually memorable I don't really
remember an action scene that stands out
to me there's a lot of action a lot of
stuff gets blown up a lot of things are
shot at but none of it was really filmed
in a memorable way not a single action
scene in this movie is more memorable
than just one action scene in t2 take
the tanker chase at the finale for
instance that is one of the best chase
scenes I've ever seen in a movie and the
action in this movie just adopted that
modern-day mentality of editing that you
have to show everything from a different
angle constantly and it's very annoying
to watch when you just we're like I'll
have shots call you cut through a
different one well I liked that one shot
and then you cut away I can't really say
the action is all that great because it
just comes off as fine and this is a
Terminator movie a franchise built on
amazing action sequences and they should
be better than fine and a friend of mine
leaving this movie said exactly what I'm
thinking right now he said I can't
recommend this movie simply because it
was slightly better than I thought it
was going to be and that it was simply
maybe alright we can't keep saying
movies are ok and that was better in
hell it was fine just have fun with it
turn your brain off
that's why Studios keep making movies
that are just ok or not that great
because a lot of people keep saying well
it's fine you can have fun and turn your
brain off the first two Terminator films
are basically sci-fi masterpieces I mean
they really are this movie should have
been a lot better than a turn your brain
off type movie but if you feel like you
will enjoy that type of movie go out and
see Terminator Genisys you'll probably
have fun with it there's some good humor
in it Arnold is great but for the most
part the action is
disappointing there's nothing terribly
awe-inspiring about it and the
characters are bland and the timeline is
kind of screwed up now and I don't
really know what they were thinking to
be honest I'm gonna give terminator
genisys a see I'm hearing James Cameron
gets the rights back for terminator in
three years
so they decide to do a sequel maybe
James Cameron can make it he's probably
going to make nothing but Avatar movies
for the rest of his life though okay
guys thank you so much as always for
watching you guys are the best I won't
take this time really quickly to just
say thank you for all the awesome emails
I get because I get a lot of emails from
people who tell me they're fans and some
that are really touching who have told
me that I've inspired them in some way
look I'm just a guy in Ohio who loves
talking about movies so that literally
blows my mind and I just want to say
thank you to all you guys and I
apologize that I can't always respond to
everyone I really wish I could but I I
can it's impossible but I really really
want to let you guys know that I
appreciate each and every one of you
thank you very much and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck my next